[Music]
we are sharing a story with you this
morning from back in time and deep under
the sea take a look at this
giant fossil of a sea reptile recently
found in the middle of england in near
pristine condition it's a skeleton
thought to be 180 million years old and
as our charlie dagetta shows us it could
help us understand our own future
it didn't look like much at first a
conservation team thought they found
maybe an old broken pipe sticking out of
the mud after draining a reservoir but
what joe davis stumbled upon has been
described as one of the greatest fossil
finds in the history of british
paleontology
a lot of people spend their careers
looking for something like this my kids
have now
named me jurassic what joe rasic
discovered lurking beneath the mud were
the remains of a monumental 180 million
year old beast a beast paleontologist
dean lomax has spent a career hunting
down
not only is this the the largest
ichthyosaur skeleton ever found in
britain but it's also the the largest
complete skeleton of any prehistoric
reptile found here in the in the uk as
well known as the sea dragon the
air-breathing apex predator ruled the
seas like a huge bloodthirsty dolphin
raising the monster from the deep was a
complex and delicate operation
that meant covering it up in plaster and
transporting it to a warehouse
and here it is and it is actually the
length of a double-decker bus around 33
feet long the skull alone is more than
six feet long and weighs nearly a ton
paleontologist nigel larkin helped lead
the excavation
what was going through your mind as you
started to uncover these segments and
thought wow we thought is it going to be
10 complete 20 hey it could be 50
complete so as we're digging away it's
just getting bigger and bigger we
couldn't believe it jackpot yeah
fantastic
a jackpot that goes far beyond what will
eventually be a pretty impressive museum
piece
what was the reason they died out what
can we learn
we can learn a lot from fossils
generally we can only predict future
climate change by understanding past
climate change and how animals like this
adapted to climate change or fail to
adapt unlocking the secrets of the deep
and the deep past may help us learn to
adapt to our own future
for cbs mornings charlie dagena
shrewsbury
england it's pretty amazing i almost
caught a fish that big down in florida
you got a way though
a florida man almost caught a fish that
happened yeah and you said that with a
straight face
never caught a fish in my life
all right we'll be right back that makes
two of us